how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we have an awesome rumor I
mean a truly amazing rumor concerning
the x-men and the Avengers and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now this is
something that we've been waiting for
for a very long time now we've had the
x-men universe over at Fox and then
we've had the Marvel Cinematic Universe
of course at Marvel Studios but now
they're both one the x-men are coming to
the MCU and they'll be making
appearances pretty soon and it sounds
like a little later on in the marvel
cinematic timeline they won't exactly be
getting along as today we have a report
that says there's going to be an
Avengers vs. x-men film later on down
the line and this is supposed to come
after an Avengers Secret Wars film and
both of these films are expected Secret
Wars is basically going to be the next
Avengers in game and ever since it was
announced that Disney now has the rights
to the x-men the Fantastic Four and
other characters from Fox everybody has
at least thought one time Avengers vs.
x-men a truly amazing event in the
comics and something that everybody
would love to see on screen and it
sounds like we're going to get to see it
so we'll talk about this report what
Marvel's plans are for an Avengers vs.
x-men film and what their plans are for
a secret Wars film and not to mention
the fact that magneto
is going to be coming to the MCU and
play a huge role in this so let's break
it all down but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe to stay up-to-date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my weekly giveaway for a
chance to win a spider-man far from home
Funko pop giveaway ends next Monday all
you got to do to enter subscribe it like
the video and comment about the video
down below so this is coming from Mikey
Sutton over the weekend he released a
lot of information of things that he's
heard about future Marvel Studios
projects and one of those things that he
has mentioned before it was Avengers vs.
x-men that he dropped on Lords of the
long boxes YouTube channel now what's
really interesting about this is that
way back in 2015 Mikey mentioned that
Fox could be doing an Avengers vs. x-men
film with Marvel Studios he talked about
Marvel and Fox playing nice with each
other and cooperating to make a film but
now of course Marvel Studios owns
of those rights to those characters so
they can do it all themselves now and it
sounds like that is their plan Mikey
says that an Avengers vs. x-men film is
going to follow a secret Wars film now
we've talked about that many many times
on this channel before that is what
everything over the next 10 years is
going to lead up to the event is going
to be just like Avengers in game but
it's actually going to be even bigger
how do you top Avengers in game you do
Avengers secret Wars
how do you top a vendor secret Wars you
do Avengers vs. x-men Mikey says that
it's claimed that both Magneto and
doctor dooms presence in the MCU will
gradually be acknowledged as Kevin Feige
wants to put magneto on the back burner
for a while due to being used by Fox but
Kevin Feige has plans for magneto that
are bigger than anything Fox has ever
done before and to touch on this real
quick
this makes perfect sense because magneto
is one of the greatest Marvel characters
ever he's great as a villain he's great
as an antihero the stories that he has
are simply amazing
but unfortunately the last handful of
x-men films that we've had haven't
really done that well especially the
latest one Dark Phoenix Dark Phoenix was
a catastrophic disaster and it had
magneto in it so it would make sense
that Kevin Feige would want to hold off
a little bit but despite that Kevin
Feige does have huge plans for magneto
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe Sutton
says figis plans are said to include
that eventually magneto will be the
primary figure in the Secret Wars film
when we finally get it it said that
magneto will be viewed as a big bad
initially but in the Secret Wars movie
magneto will lead the charge against
Doctor Doom producing an epic fight
between the two which will melt IMAX
screens worldwide it said that magneto
once an object of distrust wins over the
hearts and minds of the x-men and he'll
lead the x-men team against Doctor Doom
now in one of the Secret Wars storylines
Doctor Doom is a villain so it seems
like Marvel's going to stick true to one
of those storylines and in the original
story the x-men and the Avengers as well
as some other Marvel characters as well
were a part of secret Wars so it's truly
going to be an Avengers in-game event
but with more characters if you can even
believe that we'll have the Avengers the
x-men and the Fantastic Four along with
some other characters as well so the
question is after you do Secret Wars how
do you top that film and the answer
that's being reported here is Avengers
vs. x-men it said that magneto with the
mutants at his side except for Professor
X and Wolverine will set up Avengers vs.
x-men and I can tell you based off of
what we've currently seen in the MCU and
based off of what the story is in the
comics how exactly Secret Wars is going
to play out and how it's going to set up
the Avengers versus the x-men Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
has already mentioned that the future of
the MCU is a cosmic future that means
during phase four and phase five they're
going to introduce in some way or form
cosmic entities we've kind of already
had a few mentioned actually and Doctor
Strange Mordo mentions that his staff is
the staff of the Living Tribunal the
Living Tribunal is a cosmic beam that
maintains balance across the multiverse
and in fact the riders of Avengers in
game said that they wrote a scene in
Avengers in game where Doctor Strange
makes Thanos go face to face with the
Living Tribunal to face judgment now
obviously that was scrapped we never saw
it in Avengers in game but clearly there
are plans for them to introduce these
cosmic beans in the future and in secret
Wars
the Beyonder a cosmic beam gathers
together heroes and villains and he
takes the heroes and the villains and he
teleports them all against their will to
a distant planet that planet is called
battle world now the Beyonder created
the battle world and he stalked alien
weapons and technology on the planet and
once all of the heroes and the villains
are there he says I am from beyond slay
your enemies and all that you desire
shall be yours nothing you dream of is
impossible for me to accomplish now
there's two major things that happen
that we need to know for the future of
secret wars and Avengers vs. x-men one
thing that happens is that while all of
the heroes are kind of fighting together
to fight the villains the x-men choose
to remain a separate group they fight
the villains but they kind of fight them
on their own separate from the Avengers
the Fantastic Four and several other
heroes and the other major thing that
happens is Doctor Doom would go on to
temporarily steal the beyonders powers
and he would be in charge of battle
world now based off of this recent rumor
sounds like this is the direction that
Marvel Studios plans to go if magneto is
going to lead the x-men against Doctor
Doom in secret wars it sounds like dr.
doom is going to be the big bad just
like he was in secret Wars now we can
assume that the x-men along with all of
the other heroes the Avengers the
Fantastic Four and anybody else are
going to eventually defeat Doctor Doom
and any other villain that stands in
their way what happens after that
well with the x-men coming to the MCU
there's something else that will be
coming to the MCU as well the Phoenix
force the Phoenix force plays a very
important role with the Avengers versus
the x-men and without recapping the
entire Avengers vs. x-men series this is
essentially what happens the Avengers
and the x-men realized that a threat is
coming the Phoenix force and they
realize that it's coming for Hope
Summers they start to disagree and
eventually begin to fight on how to
handle Hope Summers as some think that
they should kill her while others don't
think that some of the Avengers
including Thor try to stop the Phoenix
force and space but they are defeated
so Ironman and giant man prepare a
disrupter weapon to kill the Phoenix
they use it on the Phoenix force but
instead of killing it the blast
separates it into fragments which bond
with Cyclops Emma Frost Namor Colossus
and magic these five characters that get
possessed with the Phoenix force would
go on to be called the Phoenix five the
Phoenix five with basically unlimited
power due to the Phoenix force would go
on to reform the world according to
their will providing free energy food
and water to all humanity as well as
ending armed conflicts around the globe
the Avengers are then summoned to the
White House and they agree that the
Phoenix five must be stopped a huge war
breaks out between the Avengers and the
x-men and Wakanda gets destroyed in the
process when Namor with the Phoenix
force attacks it but eventually the
Avengers and the x-men would end up
joining forces to stop the Phoenix five
and this is probably somewhat of a
similar story that we'll get in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe will have a
vengers Secret Wars which will probably
put a rift between the Avengers and the
x-men then the Marvel Cinematic Universe
will introduce the Phoenix force and
this will cause an even bigger rift
between the Avengers on the x-men and
this will be where they kind of start to
have conflict with another eventually
the Phoenix force will arrive and it
will end up possessing someone
multiple people and this is where the
big war will most likely happen but then
of course as the Avengers and the x-men
are divided they will end up coming
together to stop the Phoenix force and
the great thing about having the mutants
and the Phoenix force and the MCU is
we've never seen it on screen with
anything but just the x-men now that
they exist in the same universe we could
even see some Avengers get possessed by
the Phoenix force so for those of you
who are worried that Marvel Studios
can't top what they did for Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game don't
worry Marvel's got some plans up their
sleeves and it's definitely not going to
disappoint at all there's so many
stories that they could do and the Russo
brothers have even expressed interest
and coming back to direct at Marvel
Studios if there is a secret Wars film
so it sounds like not only are we going
to be getting Secret Wars Avengers vs.
x-men but the Russo brothers could be
returning as well so this is super
exciting news let me know what you all
think about this and what would you like
to see from an Avengers vs. x-men film
be sure to let me know in the comments
down below also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU for live updates you can follow me
on Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof